he had a discussion with me or sleeping
in the street dead scared like be
careful with who you're listening to
have they really
contributed to success have they really
built success or have they simply been
in a company that was successful
afterwards i've heard from journalists
that like a ton of emails were coming
from banks because they simply you know
they're threatened by our existence and
so the kind of articles and the writing
about us shifted from they're here to
screw customers over to do bad things
and that was tough i went home at dinner
with my wife and we talked about it and
i was like no this time around i should
probably help him
i decided and i tried to call him and he
didn't answer and
i emailed he didn't answer and morning
my mother called and said he was dead
[Music]
sebastian shamiatkowski he's the ceo and
founder of europe's most highly valued
fintech privately held company
his company is worth 45
billion dollars sebastian isn't a guy
that comes from a stable household or a
silver spoon
it's very much the opposite the stories
you're going to hear about his home life
his family his father
might just bring you to tears
because that's the effect they had on me
he came from incredibly incredibly
humble beginnings and he's built a
company in an industry where he was not
qualified where he didn't have technical
expertise where he couldn't code that
has completely revolutionized an
industry he is humble he is honest and
he's willing to tell you the truth and
that's why it's such a pleasure to sit
here with him today and uncover what it
takes and who it took to build such a
revolutionary pioneering business so
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire river ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
sebastian
um one of the things that i've come to
learn from speaking to a wide
array of guests on this podcast from
sports athletes to you know really
successful ceos is is how often our our
childhood and our earlier shape our
adult foundations and whenever i meet
someone like you that's achieved um
really remarkable things in any you know
in whatever discipline they're in
my first question always becomes um what
was it that made them
remarkably unique in their early years
what was the experience the cauldron
that shaped them into who they are today
right
it's kind of funny you ask that because
like i don't necessarily feel that i was
remarkably unique in my early days
i um a friend of mine uh their son
turned out to be blind
but he has perfect uh perfect pitch
and he's now eight years old and he's
sitting and playing the piano and
singing
and um
that is to me a remarkable like and i
was thinking about that i was like that
was me when i was a kid
uh look i i mean
my parents were from poland uh they
moved to sweden uh about a year before i
was born um i was born in the northern
part of sweden
um they were you know basically
immigrants because they didn't see a
future in the communist poland
you know which was the case at that time
and so um
so you know they came to sweden but
obviously as as it was back then was
very hard to integrate into swedish
society you know english wasn't as
profound as it is today and
and there was you know a lot of language
barriers at that point of time there was
also like a lot of i would say
skepticism about people with polish name
and polish backgrounds was hard to get a
job if you had a foreign sounding name
there was a lot of these biases so my
parents struggled quite a lot to
integrate my
my mother was an early retiree
uh and my father kind of jumped from job
to job was
unemployed for quite a long period of
time
drove a cab from all to your years did a
lot of different things right and so i
think that like i do think that there's
something to the fact that as an
immigrant kid
with parents that still like
intellectually had academical
backgrounds and you know had studied at
universities and stuff like that and
never basically were able to live up
fully to their potential
i do think that that kind of creates
some kind of like
you feel like that's unfair and you're
gonna like try to fix that somehow and
i was growing up among swedish friends
who just had better economical
standards than we had and i was
obviously longing for what they had
um
you know i remember that
with my mom like there were weeks when
you know we were eating pancakes every
day and i thought that was great but now
i realize it was because there was
nothing left
that was the only thing we had like
flour and milk and so forth so like
so i think that like uh i i do think
that that kind of setting and there's
obviously some research that suggests
that in silicon valley more than 50 of
the companies are you know started by
immigrant backgrounds
i do think that that kind of setting of
you know having a lot of the
intellectual capacity and and all these
things and the kind of prerequisites
potentially to do something different
and at the same point of time this kind
of drive of like you kind of almost feel
like it's unfair you know life isn't
necessarily fair but like you feel like
this is not fair we should have like
been able to have something different
than this and and maybe also to some
degree you've i don't know to what
degree that's on an emotional level i
don't think on a rational level but an
emotional level so like your parents
really sacrifice their lives like i
think it's it's hard for people that are
not have are not immigrants to
understand
the consequences of not having the
friends from school not having the you
know the understanding of how society
works which school is better which is
worse how do you interact with
government you know how does the system
works all these things like that total
lack of understanding of a specific
society that it means to shifts like my
parents did in their you know
late 20s early 30s
and how difficult that means for your
own ability to kind of you know
do something with your life i think
that's something that's underestimated
so you have the kind of emotional thing
that you want to you know you feel that
they did a massive sacrifice in some of
the regards for for your behalf right
yeah and that feels like a tremendous
privilege right yeah i wanted to ask you
um because i can relate a lot to that
i'm an immigrant myself i came from born
in you know africa in botswana and my
parents came over here my mom can't read
or write a fantastic country yeah yeah
beautiful beautiful place um but i moved
to the southwest of the uk where i was
in an all-white school of 1500 white
kids and it was was me and i caught and
we were also like
the poorest people in a middle class
area so you have
i felt different all the time yeah and
um did you feel that way yeah absolutely
very much so i mean
um even the fact that we were catholics
now i'm not a very religious person
today necessarily but we were catholics
and my you know my parents we went to to
to church every sunday and stuff like
that in a very
non-religious society like sweden that
was in itself very odd uh and i remember
people like saying you know jesus wasn't
you know the son of god and stuff like
that which at that point i'm like today
i wouldn't necessarily but coming
through that at that point it was like
you know somebody was like you know
saying things like that
and then also the poli like the view of
poland that proton was that there was
this country behind the iron curtain
that was spewing out you know uh toxic
waste into the baltic and so there was a
lot of like you know polish and jokes
about polish people and stuff like that
so i mean all of this like i took heart
i wouldn't say i was bullied that would
be in my opinion take it too far because
people
i know people have been bullied for real
and i don't think i was but there was
like that you know the sense of being
different of not necessarily um you know
both not having the same prerequisites
but also getting some like
quite a lot like sometimes getting quite
hard time over these things right and
when you were a kid because because i
know i did i developed a very naive
thesis as to how i would escape this
scenario what was that money
yeah and success yeah because it was the
pain in my household the lack of so i
thought well that will fix it did you
develop your own thesis of how to no i
think yes very similar to yours because
also what happened in my my in my life
was that my parents divorced when i was
about eight years old right um and so
and they had a lot of conflicts right on
different topics and and i think to your
point like as a child an interpretation
of the reason for that conflicts was the
lack of money like because that was what
they were talking about all the time you
were hearing that now i do today
probably have a slightly different view
of whether that was the only explanation
for their inability to you know to be a
couple and and be together but but at
that point of time i agree with you that
was like one of my interpretations was
like yes it would be nice to
um
to have you know monetary success in
life and that would solve some of these
problems for sure for sure i do agree
with that but but i also at least in in
my life there was
in addition to that something else which
i can't really explain which was that i
was always
i was always intrigued and like thought
it was interesting
to kind of do business like it's very
nerdy and i can't explain it like i
remember reading like riches branson's
book when i was like 13 years old like
and i think it was like super
interesting or the founder of ikea ingra
kamprad it was a big big thing in sweden
obviously because it says
so like i remember reading up on these
stories and i also remember like trying
to start businesses very early so i had
like i did a lot of different things in
like trying to start it was everything
from like gathering some of my friends
and we would go to the apartments where
we were living the kind of the story
buildings there was this bus stop where
all the people were coming and we would
go there and like offer us to carry you
know groceries and stuff like that for
return from like all that kind of stuff
like just finding different ways of like
you know trying to do things so
is there there's something really
intriguing about that in my mind because
um as you've highlighted immigrants tend
to be more entrepreneurial generally um
and in the situation you're brought up
in and i reflect on my own situation
because of the circumstance i had made
this connection that if i was to have
anything or become anything it would be
a direct consequence of my own actions
and then i think maybe entrepreneurship
appealed to me because
it was i knew i wasn't going to do great
in the conventional route but then this
it was this really nice route
potentially
huge success
um
um and it was all kind of centered on
what i did it was going to be me
and i think you know from hearing about
the the scenario you're in with your
parents and your upbringing and being an
immigrant
entrepreneurship uh was something that
maybe you could control if no but i
think i think you write in the sense
that like i think definitely
in that environment growing up in that
setting you know that like
there's nobody who's gonna help you like
there's nothing you're not gonna get
anything from anyone right it's just
gonna be either you do it or it doesn't
happen those are the two options like it
doesn't happen or you do it yourself
like those are the options i think if i
look at my own kids there's a lot of
things that happens in their lives that
fit into a third category it happens
because that mom helped out and you know
whatever
there's a lot of other things that
happen uh but here was like you know if
i want to have an adventure if i want to
go and see the other part of the city i
bike there i have to go there myself
nobody's going to drive me like you know
there's like and i do think that there's
some some lack of like healthiness to
that as well right where it's like it it
it kind of educates you and i haven't
thought about it but now as you're
saying it actually kind of thought about
that that it does help you but i would
also say on the immigrants like what you
said like
they are
more commonly among um entrepreneurs but
i also think that like when i look at
like you know when we have problems in
neighborhoods with a lot of immigrants
and so forth i think that to me it's
almost like
i wish that society would realize that
like
there's going to be a lot of frustration
a lot of people with like you know
energy they want something different
they want something a change they don't
want things to be the way they are
that's kind of where you're coming from
and then it's just society's ability to
try to showcase that that energy can be
used to become slot and ibrahimovic it
can be used to become you know a music
artist it can be used to become an
entrepreneur it's that energy or
if we fail to offer those opportunities
or showcase that those alternatives they
may come out as burning cars and doing
other things that are less
less you know less productive right yeah
so i think it's really that you know to
me today i was just like wish that
society would really see it as like how
do we help showcase and show that there
are these great options for that
like build up energy of wanting
something to be different right and for
that you need to sort of great empathy
and to understand that people are
different shapes and sizes yeah that
kind of brings me nicely to the
education system yeah and your your
personal experience with education
system and do you think it did you
served you well or did it fail you well
i think it did one thing that to your
point was you were describing as well in
your own history is that i i one thing
that i do worry for today compared to me
was that i was in a school
with mixed i would still say 70 80
percent were swedish
20 at that upon time were had different
immigrant backgrounds
if they would been only immigrants in
that i would not have anything to
compare to right so i do think that the
school system at that point of time was
less segregated than it is currently at
least in sweden i'm not that familiar
with the uk current situation but i
think that was that was the case so in
that case now where the teachers that
amazing and like you know like you know
there was a mix like some were good some
were bad right um
so
and i remember like you know i i was one
of the kids who had very easy at school
i learned to read quickly and and so
forth right and i believe to some degree
then i became
slightly bored because the swedish
school system at that point of time was
very much set up as like everyone equals
so if you were like a head in math or in
head in reading or whatever i i
literally still remember from like
you know second grade which is eight
years old in sweden when you're eight
years old you know um we were having
like reading which meant that everyone
was reading from a book and like some
kids unfortunately for them like they
were still
struggling really right and i had
already read the whole book so i was
quite bored sitting there listening to
the story that i already read and then i
started disturbing the lesson because
that was kind of awesome so i became
interested i became a person that was
quite problematic for the teachers i was
just like i was so under-stimulated and
that i think is a little bit sad that i
hope that like schooling has become
better in like
you know actually you know understanding
that all pupils are different and need
different support and you know can get a
different challenge because you all need
to have like a continuous challenge
right and those that lesson there you
learn about that need for challenge
you're now
the headmaster of a great school that
has thousands and thousands of employees
in it yeah and that that point about
making sure that the people that attend
your institution are also challenged
must must uh still sort of be important
to you right absolutely i think it's
like actually
you know and in a way especially in
swedish society which i you know the
swedish culture is very much this is
saying that
alaska which means that everyone should
join like everyone should be part of
this
and and that's a fantastic
ambition and vision for a society that
like no no one left behind is kind of a
different translation of it or or no
woman left behind um
but
and and for a while that was that was
creating a conflict because
clona as a company
we have very high aspirations we want to
do something very different we want to
you know really as i say sometimes play
in champions league and then you know
the problem is that's not true for
everyone in the work world some people
are fine with playing kids league and
and so forth right so
so it took us some time to
dare to say
that klono is not for everyone that
clona is actually a company that wants
to attract
um people that want to make a real
impact make a real difference they want
to learn they want to be challenged
and that took some time and it might
sound odd but for us at least in in the
swedish culture context it took some
time to get to that where we started
saying you know what klona isn't for
everyone not everyone is going to enjoy
this environment because not everyone is
we like a lot of people will say it's
amazing to climb mount everest did you
come whenever is that fantastic that's
one thing but it's a very different
thing that like how many people are
really willing to like freeze their
fingers off train for four years like
all the things that you need to do to
climb that mountain then like the number
of people that like check the box and
say i want to do that becomes massively
smaller right and because i think the
same applies for companies like a lot of
people will say i want to i want to work
for a successful growth company doing
things that's really cool
like climbing my arrows but then the
question is like are you willing to do
all these things like that that that
that means that you need to do in order
to be able to accomplish that right
and and um so so yeah to your point like
i think the challenge today i always
tell that people like
when they you know when i interviewed
them or i was just like just be like
be aware like this is you're going to be
very challenged this is not going to be
a place where like it's just going to go
easy you're going to you're going to be
very very challenged here what's the
perfect balance of challenge between
being too challenged that they you know
they end up in the
burnt outs
or under challenge that they lose
motivation like you did as a kid you
know it's super difficult right and i
think that's why it has to it has to be
about encouraging them
uh and and seeing like each individual
by individual where they are right so
think about a great personal trainer
right when you go to the gym
um you know how do they find the balance
of you know how how much to push you and
when to kind of
hold off a little bit let you you know
breed and so forth right actually you
know it's kind of interesting because um
my kids have this swim teacher her name
is petra
and and
i i can sometimes just sit and watch her
in when she's training my kids swimming
because she has that perfect pants i've
never seen a teacher that finds that
perfect balance as well as she does so
she pushes my kids exactly to the point
where they're like dead scared like
almost like they're almost there where
they're like gonna wanna they want to
give up and get out of the out of that
but they're doing it and then they're
proud of what they accomplished and and
that to me to your point like that's
almost like a piece of magic that a
teacher has like the best teachers can
spot that in their pupils can spot that
and really find that perfect balance
right but it's very difficult it's
obviously difficult in a company with 4
000 people like how do you try to put
mechanism in place to ensure that you
that you find that balance right and
that that that you really
allow people to get to that perfect spot
um where they develop heavily but at the
same time time doesn't move you know
ahead and just bang the heads to the
wall and feel uh give up or you know
to your to your point then as well about
um it took you a long amount of time to
realize that you wanted to just say to
the world and to anyone that was
considering joining your company we're
not for everyone
um the pandemic happened and what i saw
was um leaders were kind of forced in
this wave of virtue signaling to say
everyone can work from home forever
if you didn't say that now you're a bit
of an [ __ ] company and as i reflect
on that and as it went through
i started to reject that narrative
because i think that the culture of the
company should be determined by the
mission and also the other thing was i
actually think that companies as you
said should have really clear
communication at all stages about who we
are how we work and what our culture is
and allowing it to be kind of you decide
i actually think is it's it's for me
super weak as leadership but i also
think it will have an adverse effect
on the ability for the company to
achieve its mission but also the company
culture people knowing like what's
expected of them but now it seems to
have become really like except
politically acceptable to just say our
employees will do whatever they want um
how do you feel about all of that
it's a very complex topic
but but i think look i think that the
look
i give you example right is that
um
[Music]
previously which you might found odd
klono was not really following kind of
agile work tactics
and then a few years into
klonos development we realized that some
aspects of agile like daily stand-ups
weekly retros
working as small teams on specific
topics there were some aspects of these
that are very productive and really help
productivity help achieve our goals and
so forth
um
so
then what we did is we said like okay
now all teams within clone i should do
daily stand-ups to do weekly retros
and
i think currently when we look at it
our data about 50
of teams are following this right
so then the question is like how do you
then approach that because you feel
yourself very convinced that for example
the idea of daily standups is helping to
be productive
um
but if you enforce that if you simply go
and say everyone has to do this period
like check the box the problem is like
you can do daily stand-ups in very
productive ways where you're engaged the
whole team is engaged you're discussing
what can we do how can we move faster
etc etc or you can do daily stand-ups
only to check the boxes like there are
different ways and that applies to
almost all such rules and concepts
within companies
so i think that like what i'm still i
still i don't feel that i entirely
figure this out but there's a balance in
an organization around like when are we
prescriptive and mandate mandating
things and when are we suggesting and
highlighting
because in the end the reason i believe
in daily styles of so much is because of
my own experience of that but there was
also something that i seeked up myself
there was a a willingness to i was
interested in trying to find out better
ways to working i learned about this i
saw it in practice being done in a good
way and then i my conclusion was that
this was
that so if you think about my learning
process my personal learning process in
that this equation it was driven by my
interest my passion and then i
accomplished that's a very different
thing to if my board suddenly would have
dialed me up one day and said everyone
has to do daily standups period because
it didn't it would not have given me the
opportunity to learn and and reflect on
it that's when i was so a lot when i
think about learning within an
organization i think about like
the karate masters and the japanese they
kind of like remember all this like
karate kid and everything like how they
learn in those environments it is like
obviously at the beginning there has to
be an interest by the individual self to
try to learn but then the master doesn't
always tell you like exactly what to do
they like they provoke you to try to
learn yourselves right there's an
excellent example from the toyota way on
that topic where like some of the like
masters of toyota away within toyota
would like take a lot of their senior
managers and they would draw a circle on
the factory floor within toyota factory
and then the the managers would have to
stand there and observe
uh the manufacturing of the cars and
then by the end of the day you know the
totally silent teacher would come and
say
okay so tell me what have you observed
and then the the senior managers within
the circle have been standing there the
whole day had to say well we saw this we
saw that and then
he would look at them the senior you
know senior kind of shenzhen like
he would be like
no another day and i said i have to do
another day so like and as you like
provoke them because i think that's the
you know and it's very
learning is such a difficult thing right
because you don't as much as we
we think that learning is sitting in a
room and listening to somebody
um
that is you know a very inefficient way
of learning we learn by doing
uh by doing things ourselves right
that's really uh that's the truth and i
think that covert is such a good example
of that because
we had a lot of experiences that we've
never had before and they taught us a
lot about our life our priorities a lot
of people talk about that today because
we were forced to do things differently
not because we read about covey then we
read about you know how things can be
different because suddenly we had to
experience it and when you experience
that's when you truly that can impact
your behaviors can change your ways so
the the kind of it's a very difficult
balance in these companies consistently
from culture perspective like how do i
how do i encourage and kind of push
people to go and find out like you know
try to experience that and learn for it
but i
but not trying to enforce it too much
and and that's a balance game right you
cannot be entirely without rules to your
point because like if you join a soccer
team like there are some rules like you
come into exercise every morning if you
just don't come to exercise we're like
okay look uh you know maybe you have a
different philosophy about how you're
going to become a great soccer player
but like i just don't believe in your
fleet yeah like like it's not going to
work so like if you want to go and
believe that you never have to exercise
to become a great soccer player you do
that but you can't do it on my team like
right so there is obviously some
selection criteria we have to decide
within our ecosystem within our company
these are the rules that will apply and
because we just feel that they're so
fundamental and so important but once
you be on that level then it's more like
how do i intrigue you how do i challenge
you to develop that insight for yourself
so that you really come to embrace
those ways of working and really make
them your own and really expedite them i
think and i haven't solved all of this
to be very you know honestly i think we
have lots to learn still with lana but i
think that that just that is a very
interesting sorry it was a long answer
but it's amazing it's really really
thought-provoking and i was i was
thinking yeah i don't think a lot of
people would have given that answer but
i feel it's the the right one for so
many reasons especially as it relates to
the process of learning i think the
things that i was most successful at all
facets of my life were things that
started with with interest yeah and the
things that i
had an allergic reaction to in terms of
topics in school yeah were the things
that there wasn't that fundamental
curiosity so i was kicked out of school
but in if you look at business and
psychology
like i was i would have gone to more
lessons yeah i was 30 attendance in
these other subjects and that's and
that's so true so it's um it provides a
different way to i think
and i would say one more thing on your
specific like work from home thing which
is also another thing to take into
consideration is that what ends up
happening and this is not a problem when
you're 10 20 people in the startup but
when you start becoming 4 000 people
that what ends up happening is you have
obviously um unfortunately that's the
only way to describe it layers of
management and then you have the people
actually doing it and that's just how
most organizations are are structured
but what ends up happening is okay how
are we gonna do with this work from home
what are the rules they're gonna be set
and there's a tendency for people to go
and say management team the top people
have to tell us what the rules are
and
if you write those rules the problem is
like look at qlana we're active in like
40 offices across you know 20 countries
each one which will be in a different
face of covid or not and stuff like that
right so try to write a rule that is
applicable for each team and then you're
gonna have individuals maybe some
individuals have immune diseases and are
extremely wary about you know moving
into that environment are more careful
than others maybe you're going to have
like you know some people that have
religious concerns somehow tied to this
you know you're going to have a flora
because you have so many people with so
many different individuals with
different perspectives so
what you then sometimes need to do in my
opinion is you need to say look you will
decide for yourselves and what then ends
up happening is
that in my opinion what i'm supposed is
that the people actually doing the work
they usually find that
quite attractive that they can take that
decision so the managers of those people
they may find it's more difficult
because to them it's nicer that the top
management team has written a policy and
they can say like this is the rules
but why why these rules
because they were said so right and so
then they can hide behind that right and
if you don't allow them to hide behind
that they will actually have to motivate
why are we going to do like this we've
decided in this team that we're going to
work in office so we're going to do this
and that forces them to do that which is
good for them they need to do that they
need to provoke that but there's always
a risk when you write two strict rules
on the top is that they're being used
and then there's just management said so
and that is just so bad for the culture
and everything you want to provoke an
environment where people feel like the
rules are there they were well intent
they had a good purpose but they also
need to be challenged if if they on a
specific individual in a specific
situation do not apply there needs to be
a mechanism where those rules comes back
and say let's what if we're in this and
in the end rules can never be an excuse
for not thinking for yourself right that
that never happens and they always have
to be there's going to be exceptions in
a large company there has to be
exceptions because those are healthy
signs of the fact that people are
thinking for themselves and judging by
themselves and not just hiding behind
the rules such i always reflect on the
um that that made me reflect then on the
example of the someone told me certain
country i think it might be germany
where pilots were having a huge amount
of crashes
and it was because the the culture was
you don't challenge the pilot so even
when the co-pilot knew that he was south
korea south korea yeah yeah i think it
was yeah the planes were crashing but
because the co-pilot didn't feel a good
challenge yeah i think that's a sort of
uh analogous to what you were saying
there
i talk about huel a lot in this podcast
because of the transformative impact
it's had in my life um but there is such
thing as the hule bug and the reason i
started my fuel journey and became a
hooligan as they call it was because of
a guy called mike in my office back at
social chain who would evangelize about
it all the time and then once i tried it
one day and i saw the impact it had on
me i became the same type of evangelist
and even here at the diary of a ceo
studios we have now three people that
are stood currently in this room with me
that have caught the huel bug dominic
murray jack sylvester and my assistant
sophie chapman they're all now working
out and they're all addicted i think
addicted is a strong word um they're all
heavily reliant on huel to plug that gap
in their diet and their lifestyle that
a busy lifestyle and
convenience food options sometimes
create
so
i want as many people listening to this
to try huel and if you catch the heel
bug then i genuinely believe it will
change your life
i have to go back and and and hear about
the start of clana because you know one
of the things that really intrigued me
and
made me feel a lot of respect towards
you was that you're not technical as a
co-founder unfortunately no i would have
built this mega tech company but you're
not technical and i know i tried when i
was 18 that was my first failure um but
i found that really just horrifying and
respectful yeah so tell me so how did it
start and um and where did you find the
courage sure no so look as i said
previously like
it's kind of ironic i always had tons of
business ideas and i even remember like
when i uh when i was like probably 13 or
something uh
in sweden was the first time we had
private radios private radio stations
and i thought the one in my home city of
upstate sucked so i kind of wrote the
business plan for them how they should
change the shows and things and i
actually called them and tried to
convince them
yeah like i can imagine they were like
laughing their guts off like this 13
years old is calling us like you should
do this programming instead you should
have a show about this i bet they're
gutted
now exactly
so
for whatever reason i always had this
like in inclination to wanting to do
something and then um i did two years at
stockton school economics which is one
of the like top schools uh in sweden
around if you're you know want to study
at an economical direction
everyone at that point this is 2000.
everyone wanted to work with goldman
sachs morgan stanley mckinsey that was
really the the vibe it's actually
interesting because they had a survey
where they said like at that point of
time when they asked students seven
percent wanted to start their own
company today it's 70 it just gives you
like how much of a shift there's been
during that period of time but anyways
and then in 2002 because i went directly
from college to university i was like
okay i just got to do something else i
mean every all my friends had like
backpacked and stuff like that so um
ended up me and actually what became my
co-founder niklas we went back hacking
which
at that time because we always wanted to
do something that was a little bit
different
we ended up going around the world
without flying
which was a lot of fun so if you want to
go to youtube you'll find the videos
when we're like from there yeah if you
find something because they're youtubers
yeah because we had this idea that we
were this was just at the beginning of
all these like you know big brother and
all these yeah yeah you know
documentaries and stuff so so we thought
that we were gonna like we recorded the
whole thing and we did let's we thought
we were going to like air this as this
tv show that was very funny i need to
ask you one question about that how did
you get to australia without flying um
yeah so you had to uh we took a cargo
ship from singapore to brisbane uh okay
and then we had a cargo ship from sydney
over new zealand up to mexico so that's
how it worked and then we actually took
the qe2 you know a little bit for a
second uh between new york and um and
southampton so so that was gonna be the
those were the expensive parts of the
trip i mean we we did it on an extremely
low budget i think on average we spent
like ten dollars a day like we spent you
know we're sleeping in the streets i
actually slept on piccadilla circus on
the street uh when we were in london
that night and uh we were passing
through london and then i went we went
to hyde park when when the sun had risen
and slept because you don't sleep really
well and pick up that circus at the
moment
i tell you okay so like uh you can
imagine how you know the vibe there at
that point
um but anyways so we came back
and then i missed to start my semester
and so instead i was like
on the second sabbatical yeah i hadn't
expected
and it was 2003 and i was looking for a
job in my home city of uppsala and i
couldn't get a job i was actually on
welfare for a time because i just
couldn't get enough it was low economy
was very hard eventually ended up
working at this account receivables
factoring firm which was like the last
place in the world i ever thought as a
sales guy yeah and
and i was like okay but now i'm here i'm
going to do the most out of this right
so start calling and trying to sell
these services and then i it was very
difficult to sell such services to
companies because they're all like yeah
you can save me 400 pounds a year but i
don't really care because we work with
this other company for 15 years and
they're great and whatever
but then i started talking to
entrepreneurs and these entrepreneurs
were starting small e-commerce companies
because some of them had figured out at
that point of time you could buy google
adwords super cheap because nobody was
buying them yeah and then you can get
some traffic and you can sell some stuff
but like it was like it was all kinds of
stuff right so you started talking to
them and they were really keen oh i can
say 400 pounds a month a year that's
awesome i'm gonna work with you guys so
then i started like thinking about
payment services and i was asking them
what are your problems what are the
things that you would like to be solved
so that was kind of where the idea came
from
but then a year had passed and i want to
go back to school so i came back to the
stockholm school economics to start my
third year i left my job
and um but there was an incubator at the
school and it was very early at this
point of time now everyone has an
incubator but at one time it wasn't that
common so i went to the ceo of the
incubator and i said hey you know i have
this idea it's kind of payments offering
buy now pay later services it would look
like this and you know whatever and she
was like this is awesome you have to do
this
and when she said so i was a little bit
like now i can't just like give up on
this you know so so i was kind of
looking around and then i stumbled into
one old friend of my victor
uh who i knew a little bit and he was
like because i was sitting in the
cafeteria of the school and i was
telling some friends like i want to do
this company he's going to do this and
everyone was like yeah good luck to you
man
kind of like patronizing yes
kind of like fake support you do that
and i'm going to go to morgan stallion
exactly yeah like that's like that was
like kind of the
the perception so so let's go the victor
then was the only one who was like wow
that's awesome i'm with you if you do it
right so i was like okay that's cool
let's do it together we didn't know each
other that well and then nicholas who
was an old friend of mine i did the trip
around the world with so so we kind of
joined forces but then but it was still
like a huge decision to us like starting
a company at that point in time felt
like wow crazy are we giving up on
careers what's gonna happen you know so
it was only when we came to the
conclusion we were like okay you know
what let's not think about this as a
lifelong decision let's think about this
as a six-month decision i often tell
this to people today like we said like
we're gonna do this for six months
but if we do it for six months we're
gonna do like
all of our energy all of our time is
gonna be this is for the next six months
so we even had like a rule we had to eat
breakfast in the office we had to be
there we were counting the hours who
everyone else was there so it's fair so
we were like we were living in the
office for the first six months and we
were just like focus on that and nothing
else
and and but it was when we decided it
was going to be a six months and then
we're going to evaluate then we kind of
was easier to take a decision because
you're like six months whatever that's
fine right um
so so we got off
uh and then what we did uh we realized
that we couldn't code to your point
right we couldn't code we needed a
system right so we're like how are we
gonna solve that so are we gonna raise
money try to pay some engineers and hire
them what are we gonna do and eventually
we ended up the the incubator were in
they had this um like christmas drinks
thing uh where they invited some
business angels and they invited the
companies that were in the incubator to
pitch
and so nicholas my co-founder did like a
30 second pitch and after that a woman
called yane valerud
uh kind of approached us and and and she
was like you know she almost like pushed
me up to the corner she's like this is
awesome tell me what you're going to do
she was like she just heard that pitch
and she was like i like this business
idea and she tells us look i have these
engineers and they're like the best
engineers there's amazing because she
had actually done one of the few really
successful exits during dot-com area
where they had sold the company for 150
million pounds um and so she had money
from that and she had the engineering
team from that so she said i'm going to
connect you with those guys and so we
sat down with those engineering guys and
they were much more senior in us than
were like in their 40s and you know we
were 20s and
and
there unfortunately
a misunderstanding arose right where
our understanding was that these
five engineers or four engineers they
really were they were going to join us
full-time and work on this and continue
developing the company with us right
their understanding was they were going
to give us some source code some code
and a system that works and then they're
off and doing something else
and so
but you know as it is and i now try to
tell other founders this today like if
you found friends and you wanna start a
company together don't only talk about
all the amazing stuff you're gonna do
and everything you're gonna accomplish
also sit down and ask like how many
hours per week are you gonna spend on
this versus because you love exercising
and you love you know hanging out with
your friends and so forth just so like
not that you know you can do it on 30
hours a week or you could do it on 80.
but just so you're alliance you can't be
too big this alignment can be one person
doing 30 another one doing 80. make it
super concrete exactly what expectations
you have on each other because otherwise
there's just such a big risk of like
misalignment and resentment comes
quickly doesn't it right so then what we
did so we brought those engineers on
board and they started coding and
they were excellent they were amazing
engineers so they started coding the
system in december
in in april four months later we
launched with the first customer it was
four months and they put together a lot
of the fundamentals that actually still
you know today are part of what clown
offers as a service
so there was but then you know after
that they were like
good luck guys see you later and we were
like no no that's not what we agreed and
then we looked into the contract and we
had given off 37 of the company to them
for
the technology
uh and then we had given 10
to jane
uh as a business agent but she gave us
60 000 pounds right
and so um
and then so each one of us then had
equal so we had 17 each um and so that
was kind of the setup of that and then
we had basically given away now all
these percentages to these engineers and
they just left us and so that became a
quite tough conflict obviously but
legally speaking they had followed the
contract so there was nothing for us to
go into contracts and say you know
whatever because the contract was we
just we we just had hadn't talked about
this and we were on the different
assumptions of what demand the contract
was just there like we didn't think
about you know this consequence
so they ended up leaving us and it was
kind of funny because in that room at
one point of time
uh in the boardroom one person said well
you know what just so you know sebastian
you have to calm down on this topic
klona is never gonna be the size of a
company where it's gonna need four great
engineers like this
that's
did you ever resolve that sorry did you
ever
buy them buy it buy them out or no so
what ended up happening is
to some degree i think just because they
didn't understand the potential what
they had built together with us
they also sold much too early so as a
consequence i mean they sold at a very
early day where maybe the company was 10
million dollars worth or something oh
god that's awful yeah so i mean well
it's not awful in a sense because to me
it feels a bit fair yes they got the
upside of what they did if they would
have participated longer and so forth
they would have seen it very different
upside sure and they would have built
the company with us but you know but
this was a challenge for us as a
consequence to your point because at
least what it allowed us to do is very
quickly get a system live and get
something going but then as they left
i needed to figure out okay i need to
hire engineers and i have no clue how to
code and how do i evaluate a good
engineer for a bad engineer i have no
clue you're like architecture what is
that you know like there was like zero
knowledge right so you and that is one
of the biggest challenges i think for a
lot of people like managing
people that do the same thing that you
know yourself is one thing trying to
manage somebody that does something that
you have no clue how to do
is very very different how did you i was
in the same place i was i knew i needed
to build a website not technical went on
google just started looking at their own
websites right trying to using that as a
yeah this this is cool this animation
looks good
i will hire
so how did you solve that problem of not
knowing what good looks like well first
and foremost i think unfortunately um
you know in
what ended up happening in our situation
was that
um
one of the guys from this engineering
team stayed on because they were still
shareholders for a period of time right
so he stayed on as an advisor
and we started hiring some engineers
and some of you were
better some which were worse some you
know as you will always have a mix and
we also got a cto eventually who came in
um and the c he he as the cdo was an
amazing programmer and a developer
but he wasn't necessarily
the cto that would you know hire the
right talent build it he wasn't business
oriented he was very much like
technically interested and wanted to
build like really beautiful
code bases and stuff like that which you
know some engineers tend to have more of
that tendencies
and what was the frustration to me is
that
for a long period of time
and this was a challenge in sweden in
stockholm at the time the advisors that
we had around us
none of them had built
a 45 billion dollar company like we are
today none of them had that experience
but they were senior in our opinion
compared to myself they had done
great corporate big jobs we had like you
know advisors and board members that had
corporate backgrounds and been in big
institutions and and so forth and so
they were giving us a lot of advice on
topics like is this
the system that you're building is this
fast enough should you be able to build
it faster or slower like the progress
and things and so when they were giving
us that advice it was bad advice but we
were too young and too an experienced to
be able to recognize that and so
unfortunately it took us some time and
it created a lot of frustration because
i was always sitting there i was like
does it really need to take this long
time to build something
like and is it really unfair of me to
expect that the engineers are like a
little bit interested in the product
they're building as well and the
business side of it
or are they only always going to be
interested in the coding itself
and the technical challenge like
uh shouldn't i be able to engage with
them on the product side as well like
and a lot of times we were like they
were like oh we want to build this
product you need to give us more clear
specifications and i was like but if i
write those specifications what's left
to do like that's part of the creative
process to sit together and create these
so you know you get stuck in a lot of
these things and then
and then eventually i remember i was
very frustrated because at one day when
sequoia invested and that was why
sequoia was so important to us because
in 2009 we got sequoia to invest in the
company michael morris joined our board
and one of the ambitions we had with
that was to get
get it
some kind of contact point to somebody
that had actually seen large tech
companies grow had seen real success of
a tech company and start understanding
their mindset and at that point of time
i unfortunately concluded that like it
was not going to work with our cto
because he didn't have that right
mindset for it and he was interested in
something very different he's a great
guy in many ways but he wasn't the
person that would be able to allow us to
build our engineering organization and
bring us to become a true tech company
and be really technology driven
and and i remember going to the board
eventually and saying like and and at
that point of time
the representative of the engineers that
built the original system who was on my
board he had been telling me all over
and over again like i was like i'm
really worried she'd really be the slow
and he was like yeah you know it's
different there's this and that and then
eventually i came to him one day and
said look now i've taken decision
unfortunately i have to change cto and
he was like good decision and i was like
i almost wanted to smack him in your
face i was like for four years you were
telling me that this is okay and now
you're i'm doing this change and you're
saying good decision like that's not
like you should say you're wrong that
would be respecting him more right so
there was
in that setting we were coming up for
there was a it really nowadays i
appreciate much more like how i have to
really look through a person and ask
myself is this a believable person is
there somebody i should really take
advice from and i think a lot of
entrepreneurs that will listen to this
and start up people like be careful with
who you're listening to have they really
contributed to success have they really
built success or have they simply been
in a company that was successful like
those are very different different
aspects right so being very careful
about who you get advice from but that's
kind of how we saw this so it was just
like we had to learn and test
and then the last piece of very
practical advice that we did which was
one of the best things i ever did
was
because i was so mixed up like
engineering whatever what does it mean
and then i said to my cto a very
practical thing i was like hey
can you show me how you fix a bug
and so we sat down together by his
screen
and he basically took one bug that we
had and he started searching in the code
and then he wrote you know the fix and
then he wrote the test case for the fix
and just sitting and watching him do
that made a huge difference for my
understanding of like you know how long
so i think as much as sometimes you may
feel like very whatever you're managing
that you don't understand you may feel
like oh my god so difficult and to talk
about all these technical terms and so
forth sit down next to them
spend half a day spend a day just look
at when they're doing it a designer or
whatever it is something that you don't
know how to do yourself just sit next to
them see them do it and that already
will at least put you at a different
level of understanding of you know the
job and so forth so there are practical
ways in which you can try to gap that
you know bridge that gap so important
because again you comes back to
communication and i had the exact same
thing and uh i think in my first tech
business i wish i'd done exactly that i
wish i'd taken the time to go and
um build empathy towards the the role of
my my cto and um
understand what his job was and i guess
how i could make it easier but also to i
really also should have had a
uh
objective outsider come in and do an
assessment on how he was working how i
was working and everything in between i
think
entrepreneurs don't do that they
they they i think because they don't
know what they don't know exactly you
don't know that you so that's the
biggest curse in business and not only
entrepreneurs it's great managers and
leaders and people as well i think to
your point the really tricky thing is to
know what good looks like yeah right
what does good look like right oh god
yeah that's different like you judge
some work like what would great look
work work look like and it's when you've
established that understanding whether
it's in communications marketing you
know whatever you know what good looks
like then your job becomes so much
easier but the only way to find that out
obviously to your point is introducing
external people talking to people
comparing you know we also did that
actually with my cto at that point of
time which was one of the things we
actually did that led me to conclude
that i had to let him go was that
i said because i was having a lot of
dialogue like should this take this long
time and so forth so one thing i
eventually said is you know what we do
we booked meetings with five other ctos
in five large swedish companies so among
them were like erickson the more
traditional ones but it was also like a
gambling company that was doing
fantastic there was a gaming company
dice
you know stuff like that and we went and
had meetings with them and in those
meetings i started raising my concerns
and stuff like that and i was listening
to the the other company ctos answering
to the same discussions
comparing it to the answer of my cto and
in that conversation i really saw the
difference in how they were attacking
these problems and what their philosophy
is and you know and the level of
optimism in which they approach problems
yes
for sure because that's for me has been
the biggest differentiator between the
really exceptional ctos i've worked with
in san francisco when i was there yeah
versus bad ones is they have a
everything is possible attitude right
yeah and those people are an absolute
joy to work with speed and optimism in a
cto is just makes your life for sure and
again i just want to highlight here that
like my cdo wasn't bad he wasn't bad he
he was
totally fine and okay but he wasn't the
right person for this to build a 45
million dollar company yeah like right
that was just like those are two
different things right
no not exactly right he wasn't
exceptional and even have the right
mentality yeah to to do what we're doing
now
pain
yeah part of the reason i started this
podcast was because and why it's called
the divers ceos i wanted to show
um i wanted to really give a fair
impression of the other side of
entrepreneurship it's been super
glamorized it's probably why you know
that stat you you shared where it went
from seven to seventy percent that's
probably why it's now seen as a very
sort of sort of glamorous thing and i
wanted to create a bit of a
platform to share some of the harder
parts of business and listen you built a
company worth 45 billion dollars like
i know that it was painful
so talk to me about the pain and the
unexpected pain that might have put you
off starting this had you known it had
you been had you not been naive enough
to to realize how painful it is at times
well i think that like my
a lot of my pain
i would feel equals when i see
athletes
you know trying to throw or trying to
jump
and then failing and the frustration
that you see in them when they cannot
achieve what they want to accomplish i
feel that's a lot of the pain that i've
experienced so like
my a lot of my frustration and pain has
been associated with like oh
you know i know we can do this i know we
have the opportunity to do this and
we're just not getting there we're not
getting there it's not getting through
it's not happening the way it could be
i think that's a big piece of a pain
for me is that lack of like ah so
frustrating to feel like you're so close
something could be there but it's not
that um i think that that's one part
then
i mean
another part is obviously
you know when things go wrong and you're
frustrated because
you know you wanted something to be
better and it didn't work out and stuff
like that so you're very like
uh you're challenged by those situations
in terms of stress how do you feel that
and have you dealt with that
um
i am not that stressed to be honest i
don't know why it's almost like to some
degree i'm almost more stressed when
things are good
no because like like when we have some
crisis or something happens right like
you know we had an incident with some
breach of data
for example a few months ago right
in those situations as much as it's
painful that something's happened and
i'm sad about potential consequences for
individuals that we might have made some
errors
i feel like it all becomes like
execution mode we bring everyone into
room it's just like what do we do what
do we do now
and i kind of in a way enjoy that work
it's very concrete it's very like you
know focused and you're like there's
nothing else you have to do only this
now let's see about what can we do about
this problem how are we going to fix it
who's doing what you know and so forth
in those situations i don't feel that
stressed actually i can even feel an
adrenaline in that situation as much as
it's painful to me to see the
consequences i give you an adrenaline in
like let's get this to work let's do
this now let's you know let's take on
this challenge that has suddenly arise
um it's funny the best leaders and i'm
sure you'll find this even in your
company all seem to speak to that they
all seem to be really emotionless in
those the absolute chaos moments right
and it becomes a you know a methodical
process of how to solve the problem yeah
versus and and i do think again as much
as you know i don't want to
obviously
i feel a lot of pain from the
perspective of like if we've done a
mistake or done something wrong as a
company it might have had implications
for customers or whatever that's very
painful but at the same point of time
those incidents or the situations when
you've gone through something that was
very chaotic or very challenging
are the moments that have created the
strongest relationships within the
companies have shown you know has
shown some amazing talents stepping up
to like
it's a little bit like you go on a
vacation it's just sunny you don't
really remember it but if you had like a
you know a thunderstorm you'll talk
about it for for years right so like
there's something to that um so i think
my stress may actually more come from
sometimes when i feel like
we're all kind of happy we all feel it's
going well like it cannot be true there
must be something that's wrong yeah and
i think alex sitting over there will
well um we'll kind of smile now you see
i think you will recognize this but like
um so i think that that's where i can i
actually more get stressed from like are
we doing fast enough is this good enough
like that's really interesting i i it
kind of also relates to your point about
bit needing to be challenged you talked
about in school when you'd read the book
and you got bored
and that it's funny because i i was
writing my book and i finished writing
my book recently and it was published
and one of the paragraphs in it talks
about how i used to believe that my life
was the pursuit of trying to get to
stability yeah but in fact when you look
at when people arrive at a point of
stability yeah everything is fine yeah
when they've won the gold medal then
they descend into chaos yeah then they
get depression and they get they lose
their sense of purpose and then they
they get irritable so i flipped it and
thought you know my life is actually the
the the pursuit of staying in chaos
because chaos is my stability and if i
ever get to stability completed goals
nothing to strive for then i descend
into chaos yes and it sounds exactly
like what you've described that's buying
and working for things is so motivating
important i think to somebody as much as
kalona had a lot of success in europe
there's a kind of funny story around
this topic because
um you know we were doing really well in
europe and developing our services but
there wasn't necessarily that much
fierce competition from one perspective
right and then as we were moving into
the u.s market there's this company in
australia called afterpay run by nick
and they're competing head-on with us
right and they were doing really well
this is back in like 2018
and i was like ah this is so annoying
like they're coming in here they're
taking our market share they're doing
our product they're copying us you know
all this frustration building up and the
funny thing is i happen at that point of
time to be visiting with mahmoud who
runs boohoo right good friend yeah so
i'm sitting there with my mood and i'm
like complaining to him and i'm like
look
it's a little bit like you know you know
the olympics when there's this guy who's
been like this is his fourth olympic and
everyone knows like now finally he's
gonna get the gold matter because he's
been training like and then this young
guy comes from nowhere
and like but that's so unfair this is my
fourth olympic and this guy comes in and
mahmoud looks at me and he's just like
sebastian shut up
stop whining stop whining and like this
is gonna make you so much better you
have been not having proper competition
you now have proper competition and it
is so true klauna in the last three
years thanks to the competition with
afterpay in the us has become such a
much better company it has helped us so
much to improve to get focused like and
it was just so funny when he was just
like stop whining
and i can't you know he will speak his
manchester i can't do that i won't be
able to try to to replicate how you
express this but i thought it was really
funny well that's my mood i remember the
first time i met him um i was in his
office four days that week and he
insulted me several times but in the
most loving way like you remember him
smashing his pen on the desk and telling
me how stupid i was because of a
decision i was going to make and we've
been i've been like good family friends
with with the whole family for a very
very long time yeah
what was interesting just on that point
then what was the toughest moment in
your clan journey
a moment you think that was that was it
similar to there's been some media
scrutiny of us in the uk
we had a similar experience in in
swedenborg a few years earlier which was
in around 2012 and 13.
and and like it started off with this
like media inquiry about what we were
doing because we were you know first
just like oh it's an amazing successful
company and otherwise people are like oh
we're actually doing credit and what
does that mean and stuff like that and
so they started to be in quite a lot of
like and it actually started with a
mistake that we had done internally it
was an operational mistake we've done a
stupid thing um and and that had
resulted into a lot of customer
complaints and stuff which was our own
fault but that was the beginning of it
and and i think through that process
when the paper started writing about us
in a negative way
um
i kind of jumped in and it's kind of
funny because i was actually at that
point i had comments fields on the
articles so i would go into the comments
field and write my responses in real
time and then other
consumers and readers would answer and
then i would answer them and even the
newspapers started writing about like
look sebastian ceo is on our forum
discussing the topics so i was very
engaged i was sitting like working 24
hour and i was thinking about like how
do we give because
quickly the media went you know out of
control and there was a lot of bias and
and you know inaccurate reporting and
just like a lot of things some were
accurate and some was fair but a lot of
it was also like
out there
and then obviously the banks because we
are a big threat to the establishment
banks so
even you know afterwards i've heard from
journalists that like a ton of emails
were coming from banks saying like oh
you know they're bad they're this
they're that or whatever because they
simply you know they're threatened by
our existence and so
um so there was that going on
but i remember what was the hardest
thing to me to point is that that
situation itself was fine but at some
point of time
the
um
uh the kind of articles and the writing
about us shifted from
they're bad they've done these mistakes
to they have bad intent they're here to
screw customers over to do bad things
right and that was tough that was really
tough because i know that wasn't true
and i know that we have good intentions
and we're trying to do that we have done
mistakes and we can fix things but being
judged and questioned on your intentions
of what you had yes that hurt a lot and
i took that very hard and i took that to
heart
um so that was very very challenging to
cope with when those things happen
what kind of partner do you become to
your
your romantic partner your wife you
gotta
yeah
she knows that i'm like extremely
passionate about clanna and the company
and and i think that she's
um
she knows that like a lot of my thought
process will be here all the time right
so i think that but but you know i'm
very lucky in the sense that nina
is an amazing uh person herself she's
done amazing things and now she's
running a startup with 30 people
so that helps because she has her own
like things and and actually we can come
together at dinner table and we can you
know um
we can talk about the challenges and the
things that we um
that we face
and we can exchange thoughts about that
so it when we have three kids as well
right i have a four-year-old and a
six-year-old and a seven-year-old so um
so i actually you know as much as i live
my life i try to
work really hard and then come home turn
off the phone
be very present with the kids and then
they go to sleep and then i get to work
some more
and then me my wife has a very like
which is i think maybe most
families with kids our age but you have
a very strict you always thought that
wasn't gonna happen you're gonna stay
spontaneous and all that yeah yeah you
end up having an extremely strict
calendar was like wednesday is dinner
night me and nina have dinner together
tuesday we're working like nights and so
forth so it's extremely strict calendars
to make that
work
quick one as you probably know by now
i'm trying to make my life a little bit
more sustainable and i consider myself
to be on a bit of a sustainability
journey in the same way that i'm on a
health journey and it's a privilege to
be able to share that with all of you
and you you'll know if you've listened
to the last podcast that i traded in my
range rover sport in for an electric
bicycle which is now my only vehicle and
next year hopefully i'll have my
electric car too if tesla hurry up with
a cyber truck and that's where my energy
comes into my life and my sort of
sustainability journey it makes your
life if you are on that sustainability
journey ten times easier this is one of
the if you can't see this i'm holding in
my hand if you're listening on spotify
or apple this is one of their renewable
energy products if you're watching on
youtube you'll you'll see this this is
called the harvey it's this very clever
little device that allows the zappy and
the eddie which i've talked about before
on this podcast to be installed into
your home without hard wiring or without
batteries or without those um god-awful
transformers that a lot of people have
in their house it's basically a tiny
device that's going to save you both
time and money and for someone like me
who doesn't have loads of time on our
hands it's a real life saver if you're
looking to make a conscious switch and
you need a quick fix that's going to
save you a load of time then head over
to myenergy.com to see this product and
many many more
you're a you know grew up from very
humble beginnings with an immigrant
family as you've said and because of the
success of kalana that's now made you
very wealthy
and it's something well beyond probably
you've ever imagined i don't know how
ambitious you are but um what role does
that that play now in your life in terms
of your relationship with money it was
the thing that as you say you thought
might have been liberation from a lot of
pain and heartache and what role does
does the financial um side of it success
come
turn your life i think it's an
interesting topic and you know i've been
asked sometimes like the classic
question like does money make you happy
right
and
and you know
i i understand why some people try to
say no it doesn't because to some degree
like you're the same person even if you
have a different income level and wealth
than you used to have so you're the same
person you still get angry at things and
sad at things you know still things
happens you you lose a relative or
something happens in your life you know
you go up and down
so from from one perspective i can
understand why people but i've stopped
saying that because i actually think
that it's slightly out of touch i mean
there are elements in my life i don't
have to worry about like i mean i can
still remember the feeling
of like you know i used to go into
7-eleven and i would be like i would
just love to have orange juice but i
can't afford it or i would just love to
have sneakers or i would just like like
and i remember the day coming in into
7-eleven like it doesn't matter i can
buy whatever i like in the store it will
have no impact and that is a difference
and i just you know i think it's a
little bit like out of touch to say that
that doesn't impact you i don't have to
worry i never worry about finances like
it's all taken care of right and that
obviously creates a different
life
it gives you a different thing then i'm
not a big like i'm i don't like have 10
cars or anything like that i'm not going
to be interested in cars like like i
said i'm not necessarily the person i
have a couple of things like i have for
example my i'm very very proud that i
bought a steinway piano that is
self-playing oh yes so you actually have
this like app like spotify you can go in
and select perfect and you can sit there
do the video yeah exactly pretend that i
have learned to play piano as well so
like i have some like luxuries that i've
really afforded myself that i think we
have in a beautiful house and
and things like that but
but it you know but i still think that
like the key thing is i don't worry
about it and i know that most people and
i remember myself worrying about it
right worrying about next month end of
you know end of these things and and
that is a difference in life obviously
right so that has changed i read
something which was um was quite
difficult to read actually which was
about your father and his response to
your success yeah not being
not being particularly proud necessarily
of your success yeah but that also comes
back to alcoholics like because
so whatever happened in my uh my life
right is that um my grandpa
unfortunately drank himself to death and
then
when i was growing up my father was very
conservative and i never saw alcohol in
our house and he barely had a bad glass
of wine and unfortunately that started
changing in my like teens
so i started discovering bottles of
vodka at home and so forth and then
over time uh there were instances where
i would come home and that would be
quite drunk and and act in a very
irrational way and he became more
aggressive and and so forth and
and and this was at a point of time
where i was still out partying and
drinking and so forth and it was
interesting because at that point of
time
as and that just tells you about you
know the problems of alcohol uh um
addiction
i never reflected that maybe i have a
problem as well all right that was like
out of
of course not like it was my father who
had an issue right
and but
he unfortunately found himself in a
spiral in his life where
and i think it's almost like people find
themselves in a positive spiral negative
spiral the positive spiral is like you
know what i can actually affect my own
life and now i'm going to try a little
bit
things get better you know what i can
maybe do even more i can do even more
and then some people are on that
positive part what other people find
themselves in the negatives pirate was
like i have found myself in this it's
not my fault it's everything else's
fault
and then you know things get even worse
and a look and they just found some in a
very negative spiral and obviously i'm
simplifying people are different in all
these situations but there's something
that and that found itself in that
spiral where it was everyone everyone
else and alcohol tends to
extrapolate that and make it even
stronger that you you basically blame
everything else and you take not don't
take the responsibility that's the
beginning of the 12 steps of the
anonymous alcoholism is actually to take
responsibility for your own actions and
so
unfortunately and it
it it went as far as as um you know he
he lost his job he he lost his apartment
and uh and i found myself in a very
tricky situation because at some point
of time my economical situation was
improving heavily and i was trying to
figure out what what do i do now because
he could call me and he would ask for
money
and i would be like
of course i want to help my father and
so i would help him and then if i did
that i didn't hear from him for a couple
of days and then he would call me super
drunk or text me something very you know
nasty
and so it was very difficult because and
then i started seeing counselors and
understanding that like maybe actually
in this situation i needed to put like
limits
you know and and ask him to not um
uh
to say look i'm not going to do this
unless you know you do this and stuff
like that which was kind of the right
way to deal with it but very very
obviously tricky and unfortunately
in my situation it didn't it didn't work
so at the end there was a situation
where you know um
he was
um
he was about to lose his apartment and
he had a discussion with me and i was
very like ambiguous should i help him
shouldn't help him and on and um
and then i was it was an evening in the
office and suddenly i see my phone's
phone number he's calling me on the
phone
and i was like i don't know yet what the
right answer is should i help him or not
what should i do it's difficult
so i was like i'm going to call him
later so i didn't answer the phone
i went home had dinner with my wife and
we talked about it and i was like no
this time around i should probably help
him
i decided and i tried to call him and he
did an answer and
i emailed he didn't answer and i was
like okay fine maybe just you know
whatever and then in the morning my
mother called and said he was dead right
so it was a
so that was like a very very obviously
dramatic moment in my life and very
difficult like you know from that
perspective so
um he he was so smart
he was so thoughtful he had gone to
the places we had worked he had tried to
do things better and so forth but he had
been in normal places where if you know
i remember him working for the
municipality for example and he integra
like he created some excel systems that
would rationalize everybody's work and
nobody wanted to rationalize their work
because that meant that they would have
less to do and maybe somebody would lost
their jobs so he's doing all these
things and nobody was showing gratitude
to his attempts of trying to fix things
and things similarities to what i'm
doing i could see him having those
things but because of his background
because of the situation and to some
degree probably because of his you know
addiction he just found himself in this
negative spiral rather than the positive
spiral that i found myself in and it
just made him you know more depressed
and and that made him also very
difficult for him to relate to me
because like
in one way i
must believe in hope that at some point
of time he was proud and and you know
happy about how things have evolved in
my life but at the same time time
it was very clear that he felt
frustrated by the fact that what he had
gotten and how his life had turned out
compared to mine
as crazy it might seem that your father
would relate in those terms but i think
unfortunately that was part of the case
so
you know it's very tricky and difficult
and but i'm very happy at least that i
stopped drinking and i'm a i'm a sober
alcoholic since
nine years now so amazing yeah well done
my last question then um that was
incredibly you know incredibly moving
for so many reasons and i think it's um
it's really also inspiring that you have
that sense of sort of empathy to be able
to look back at you and your father and
understand that a lot of his um
circumstances came from his own pain and
that was a generational cycle yes one
that you you have the power to
just to stop yes i say and um and also
to kind of it sounds like you've kind of
forgiven him
for yeah i have because look i i think
you know people i don't think people
still fully understand
alcoholism in my opinion it is a disease
he was sick
he hadn't you know he had an addiction
yes was he does that mean that he
couldn't cure himself no he could cure
himself if he would have found himself
on a positive spiral he might have been
able to cure himself that doesn't mean
he wasn't sick this the father that i
had last years was not my true father
those are not the memories that i have
from my youth when he would bring me
into the forest outside uppsala and we
would go on long walks together and we
would fantasize about being space
explorers or he would introduce me to
amazing science fiction literature one
of these things like there are different
memories of my father that was my true
father that was a sick man
and and that's just unfortunately like
how things develop right so i know
you're a father um three beautiful kids
um
what matters to you uh in terms of the
the principles in which you you hope to
raise them and obviously now as we
talked about the start of this podcast
um much of the
the i guess the the circumstances that
created you were because you you were
you went without and you didn't have new
things handed to you and you formed that
connection that if i'm going to be then
it's going to be a direct result of my
actions so what do you what's your
thinking is and what you want to impart
on them and well yeah
it's a topic i
tend to talk a lot about with my wife
and that's very difficult
um i mean it's a mix right because first
and foremost like
obviously my kids are not gonna have the
same upbringing that i had like there is
a massive difference like you know look
at our vacations look at our summer
house look at like all the things this
is like there's no way i'm going to be
able to ever like recreate any of that
but um but that's you know that's part
of it and i but i do think also like
when it comes to being spoiled like to
some degree to be entirely fair like and
i love my mother she's amazing but she
did spoil me she had a very hard time
saying no and if we were in this grocery
store and there was some candy and i
would be like i want candy she tended to
give me the candy so i'm a pretty
spoiled person by my upbringing even
though we didn't have that much
financial means now she wouldn't buy the
candy if there was no money left but if
there was money left she tended to buy
it and then there was no money left for
something else right so like she had my
my especially my mom had a very hard
time putting nose to me and she would
say yes to basically everything as long
as she could basically right um so you
can spoil somebody without having
financial means to some degree right um
now uh so that's one thing but but there
is something where i've you know and it
was funny because now that's like
my son was invited to like a you know a
party a birthday party with some of his
friends like six years old right and
you're standing and talking to the
parents and we have this amazing school
it's not a privacy it is a private
school but it's not
kind of though like upper-class private
schools it's actually a really nice
school with a good mix of people from
all types of society and stuff and but
very ambitious teachers and and a good
school
and and
we're starting that and the other
parents are a little bit like
complaining about like you know oh this
could be better and this could be better
and i it's not like i didn't agree with
them that some things were
um
couldn't be improved in our school as
well as there always can be but then i
told them to i then like stopped them a
little bit and i said you know what i to
be honest like for myself if i think
about the schools that i went to and the
environment i brought up into i
sometimes wonder whether i want my kids
to continue going to this very good
school or whether
maybe when they're like 12 or 13 i'm
gonna try to find the worst school in
sweden and put them in there for three
years just to create a little bit of
resistance like to get something like a
different perspective on like be an
environment where it's very difficult
and like i was like because i really
want them to get the resistance i want
them to
get to know themselves and get to know
that they can actually fend for
themselves that they can solve these
problems for themselves i don't want
them to be without resistance and i feel
like all of our parenting today is about
like removal resistance and i'm like no
i want some resistance and the funny
thing is i'm telling this to the other
um parents and they're all looking at me
like is he stupid
is he is he wacko like what's wrong with
him like you know and i was like no no i
want some resistance right and i
remember that just to to round off look
when we did that roundabout trip
we had very little money on that trip
and at some point the time we arrived
from singapore to to to brisbane and we
were going down to sydney and we were
actually supposed to take the cargo ship
the next day
to go to
us already so we're only going to stay
one day in australia but
we missed the boat we had an unfortunate
event that we came too late and the
cargo ship was not going to wait for two
passengers i promise you so they just
left
and we went to the firm that helped us
find these cargo ship trips and they
said sorry next boat is in a month
and we're like okay but we don't have
any budget no money and now we're like
stuck in australia for a month obviously
quite a nice place to be stuck honestly
but but still like
and i remember walking down the street i
think it was elizabeth street or
something in in sydney and i remember
that like i have no job i have no money
i have nowhere to stay i have only my
backpack
and you're like and we're gonna stay
here for a month let's try to start a
life and we had to find a place to live
that was affordable and we had to find a
job and we actually started working as
uh furniture movers for a company called
city move everyone worked they call it
chitty move because they have this about
but but it was okay and we were in and
so but the point is that like
it taught me i can fend for myself i'll
survive
and like it's only dependent on me and
that resistance created a sense of like
you know i can do this and so forth
right and so
that's what i hope to give my children
somehow but how do you do that if you
pass them your wealth
well i'm not sure i'm going to pass them
the world so i actually have officially
said in some interviews in sweden that i
am and my wife and me are still not
entirely aligned on this topic but i
have actually said i'm not going to give
them anything and i tell them in that um
and it was even funny because you know
in sweden i'm quite well known so even
the fact that i said so on public tv
then my kids heard from their friends
like dad you said on tv that you're not
gonna give us anything that's unfair we
were like i don't like stuff no but i've
been telling you consistently like when
you're 18 years old you're on your own
like and then my wife always goes we may
buy an apartment for them right and i
was like i'm not sure let's see like i
just
there is to your point like i mean
i don't i don't want to like and and in
sweden also it's a little bit
provocative for somebody with money to
say i'm not going to give anything
because i i don't i'm not saying i don't
believe in welfare i think sometimes you
need to support people in in difficult
situations and so forth so i said look
i'm not talking about people in general
i'm only talking about my kids but for
my own kids
i'm not convinced that giving them all
of this is gonna make them happier and i
meet a lot of people from
family wealth that have inherited wealth
that are extremely unhappy with the
pressure and the expectations that comes
with that so as much as
and again i i'm not saying that money
doesn't make you happy we've all talked
about it but like there are some aspects
of it that are very difficult and i
think that like in general
building a person's own
self-confidence and belief in their own
abilities to actually have a positive
impact on their lives i still still
think that that is the key
you know path to happiness
i agree
listen sebastian thank you so much for
your time and your honesty and your
humility and um you're a massive
inspiration to me for so many reasons
thank you at least for your business
success but i really do come back to
that point about you building such a
great tech company without technical
expertise i hear it all day every day
from entrepreneurs i felt it myself i
think i've told myself that there's
certain industries i can't build in
because of that because i lack
fundamental expertise there um and i
think you you kind of booked that trend
and proved to me an entrepreneur's
listening that you can um if you have
the drive and determination and that's
underlying self belief to get there what
you've done is just absolutely
phenomenal thank you very much
unbelievably pleasant human being as
well and um you're very sort of very
very honest and i think that's um that's
a gift that i'm glad you shared with us
thank you
um but yeah thank you so much for your
time and i can't wait to continue to
watch your journey it's been a pleasure
it's gonna be exciting thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you